وزير الخارجية ، أنت تعلم أنه حتى
قبل وجود القاعدة أو أسامة بن
لادن في 9 11 ، كان العالم يركز
بسبب
حكومة طالبان الأصلية على
القسوة والتجاهل التام
للمرأة في أفغانستان ، كان هذا
مشكلة منذ
ما يقرب من 30 عامًا الآن
أو  ما لا يقل عن 20 عامًا في
أفغانستان ، هل تهتم قطر بما يكفي
بحقوق المرأة
لتضع أقدام طالبان في النار.
جعلهم
مسؤولين عن هذه القضية بالذات ، من
المؤكد أنه من المهم جدًا
بالنسبة لقطر ومن غير المقبول بالنسبة لنا
أن نرى أي سوء معاملة للمرأة في
أفغانستان ولا
يمكن التسامح مع رؤية أفغانستان تنتقل إلى
أرض خصبة للإرهابيين
والإرهابيين.  المنظمة التي كنا
ندعو إليها لهذا الحث على هذا
ونحن نرسم مثالاً
كدولة قطر كمصمم  دولة ليم مع هذا
بنظام إسلامي
ولدينا عدد من النساء والمشاركة
في القوى العاملة الحكومية
أكثر
من الرجال وأيضًا في
التعليم العالي لدينا نساء أكثر
من الرجال ونبين لهم أن
هذه أمثلة  بالنسبة لبلد مسلم
يمكنه التقدم بمشاركة نشطة
للمرأة ولا
يوجد في ديننا ما يمنعهن
من الذهاب إلى المدرسة أو السماح
لهن بالبقاء في المنزل فقط وهو أمر غير
مقبول على الإطلاق بالنسبة لنا في دولة
قطر ،
هل يمكنني ذلك  أسألك الآن عن قطر
يبدو أنها قوة إستراتيجية جديدة نسبيًا ،
ليس فقط أنك
استضفت المفاوضات مع إدارة ترامب
وأه وطالبان ،
لكنك لست بحاجة إلى أن أذكرك أنه في
ظل الإدارة الرابحة
حاولوا ذلك  كان هناك شعور
بأن تحالفًا مناهضًا لإيران بين المملكة
العربية السعودية وإسرائيل والإمارات العربية المتحدة ، كانت إدارة ترامب
بحاجة لعزل قطر
التي من الواضح أنها قد اكتملت و
أنت أي شيء غير معزول ، ما
هو شعورك حيال ذلك ، أعني هل
تشعر وكأنك قد تم تبرئتك
ما الذي تشعر به
جيدًا في الواقع ما حدث أه في عام
2017 وعندما بدأت أزمة الخليج
، فقد أثرت على  تقدم
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بشكل عام وله
تأثير أكبر على المنطقة الأكبر
والمنطقة الأوسع ، وقد رأينا
أن سياسات العزلة أو الأزمات
دون
المشاركة والحوار لن
تؤدي إلى أي مكان ، وكنا
إيجابيين للغاية ونشارك بشكل بناء
مع  شركاء دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي الآخرون ويسعدنا
أن نرى التقدم
بعد قمة الله وعودة الترميم
إلى الخليج وقد رأينا
رغبة واستعدادًا من
أعضاء مجلس التعاون الخليجي الآخرين لاستعادة
دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وستكون قطر
بالطبع
منخرطة بشكل إيجابي في  تلك الجبهة في
الشأن الإيراني نرى أن إيران جزء من
منطقتنا إيران جارتنا نحن
محاصرون كما هو الحال مع السعودية مع
الإمارات واه دول الخليج الأخرى
إيران جزء من ذلك  الحي
ونشجع دائمًا جميع الأطراف
وكل الحي بأكمله على البدء
في الانخراط معًا وعلينا
تحقيق الاستقرار في منطقتنا من خلال المشاركة من خلال
الحوار ومحاولة الاتفاق على الأقل على
المبادئ الأمنية التي نضمن
عدم وجود
أي منها  القضايا
التي يمكن أن تواجهنا يمكن أن
تتدهور أه الوضع الأمني لدينا كا
ت دول الخليج لفترة طويلة عا
ل الاستقرار في منطقتنا ون
تاج إلى أن نبقى كع
مل استقرار ونبقى مستقرين وهذا لن يح
ث إلا بالحوار هل يمكنني التحول إل
قضية مختلفة تمامًا ولكنها واحدة
من أكثر دول العالم التي
تحب كرة القدم في العالم
متحمسة حقًا وهي كأس العالم
التي ستقام في قطر في غضون
عام تقريبًا من الآن ولكن مجموعات حقوقية
المهاجرين أثارت
هذا الأمر باستمرار  مشكلة حقيقية أن العديد من
العمال المهاجرين قُتلوا
وماتوا في أوضاع غير آمنة وهم
يشتكون من أن حكومتك لا
تفعل ما  في ذلك يتعهد بالقيام إما بالحفاظ على
سلامة هؤلاء العمال أو حتى التحقيق في
ما يحدث لماذا لا
يستمر هذا وزير الخارجية لفترة
طويلة وبالتأكيد هو وصمة عار على كتاب النسخ الخاص بك
حسنًا أه مسيحي أعتقد
أن ما تم إحرازه من تقدم
قطر
في مقدمة
حقوق العمال وحقوق الإنسان في
السنوات العشر الماضية
هي شيء متقدم على المنطقة بأكملها
،
وقد أقرت جميع الإصلاحات والقوانين ومشاركة الحكومة في تلك الجبهة مع مختلف المنظمات الدولية والمنظمات غير الحكومية بنشاط كبير.
كل التقدم الذي حققته
قطر للأسف كان هناك الكثير من
التضليل والإبلاغ الخاطئ
عن الحقائق والأرقام
أه حياة أي شخص يعيش في
قطر تهم الحكومة كثيراً
ولا يمكننا أن نتركها
هكذا بدون أي شيء.  المساءلة
والحكومة تنطلق
دائما في حال وجود أي حالة وفاة أه
تحقيق حولها
وعقدوا ص  المراقبون في الحقيقة
بالأرقام التي تنشر عن
الوفاة على كأس العالم أه
المواقع مضللة والأرقام أه
عدد الوفيات التي تتعلق
بمشروعات المونديال في السنوات العشر
الماضية كانت لثلاث عمالة فقط لذا
أعتقد  المعلومات الأكثر تضليلًا
والتي تُستخدم أحيانًا للأسف
للإبلاغ هي تضليل
الرأي العام حول الوضع
هناك ، لذلك كنا منفتحين للغاية ودعونا
الجميع للحضور إلى جوهان لرؤية
التقدم هناك
بأنفسهم ونحن فخورون بالتقدم الذي أحرزه
لدينا أنك تعرف حسنًا بسرعة كبيرة
أيضًا ، فنحن دائمًا ننظر إلى أنفسنا
أيضًا إذا كانت هناك أي ظروف
جيدة ، أردت فقط أن أسألك
عن شيء التحسين ، لقد
نفد الوقت حرفيًا ولكنه لا يزال يمثل
مشكلة.  أريد فقط إجابة بنعم أو لا ،
هل تعلم إعادة فتح التحقيق أو التعمق في
التحقيق إذا تم استدعاء ذلك الآن
بالتأكيد إذا كان هناك
أي شيء يتطلب أي شيء  تحقيق من
قبل الحكومة وتحمل
المسؤولية عن ذلك وسوف تفعل ذلك